- There's one part of the phone call
between President Trump
and Brad Raffensperger
that I find particularly worrying
apart from the whole potential
election interference thing,
and that's the,
Secretary of State Raffensperger said
that he never planned
on releasing that tape
unless President Trump
disclosed it and lied about it,
which the President did via tweet.
- It was a private conversation
as far as I was concerned.
He broke privacy when he put out a tweet.
- That means that apart
from the whole criminality
of the whole call.
If the President hadn't
opened his big mouth,
we might not have ever
learned about this call,
which might be criminal, it might not be,
but in any event, it's extremely worrying.
Raffensperger was on notice
because of four years
of the Trump Presidency
and the fact that he
received 18 attempted calls
from the President.
He knew that something was up.
But the really worrying
part is that President Trump
has probably made dozens
or hundreds of such calls
that we'll never hear about
because they were either never
recorded or never released.
If you'd like to learn if the call itself
was criminal or not, check
out the whole 20 minute video
that I did on whether
the call was illegal.
And as always, I'll see you in court.